kranke risikogruppen mitarbeiter im
gesundheitswesen aber auch polizei und
feuerwehr sollen zuerst geimpft werden
wir haben uns mal umgehört was die
menschen von dieser impfstrategie halten
und ob sie sich auch zuerst impfen
lassen würden
ich habe sehr viel vertrauen der
regierung das ist genau die gruppen die
das größte risiko haben und auch am
nächsten im einsatz sind das desaster
bekommen also ich würde heute sagen
endeffekt zum gesetz alle gleich oder da
gibt's kein ist general motors ist das
jetzt zuerst natürlich das
pflegepersonal und die ärzte das ist
ganz klar
und natürlich die risikopatienten und
dann die leute die in die schule gehen
müssen also die lehrerinnen und lehrer
und dann natürlich die älteren leute die
ja auch gewisses risikopotenzial haben
beim impfen da stehe ich mal so ein
bisschen skeptisch gegenüber da man die
langzeitfolgen nicht kennt und deswegen
würde ich es mir gut überlegen ob ich
mich impfen lasse
vielleicht würde ich mich eher gegen
erkältung impfen lassen als gegen einen
also mit einem neuen impfstoff gegen
korona wir gehören auch zur risikogruppe
und da würde ich mir gerne in meiner
schöne haut noch bieten lassen
wenn da impfstoff in ordnung ist also
kaum nebenwirkung tatsächlich kein
problem ich ohren zu lassen
die reihenfolge in der geimpft werden ok
ja aber gerade so wie ich gerade arbeite
im risiko betrieben wo ich gerade
arbeitet die würde ich dann auch mit
etwas vorziehen
allerdings frage ich mich dann ob dann
die leute die nicht im risikobereich
sind eventuell wieder welche anstecken
und so weiter das ist dann halt trotzdem
kein ende nimmt also klar sicherlich
wird es wahrscheinlich besser aber
schwer einschätzbaren bis das irgendwie
bisschen sicherer und erprobte ist weil
ich jetzt ja also älter bin als ich bin
jetzt 80 und habe also die korona zeit
gut überstanden und bin jetzt nicht so
eilig darauf sofort den impfstoff haben
zu müssen
der würde bissel warten und ist ein
bisschen absetzen ich würde mir wünschen
dass mindestens 40 50 prozent sich
wirklich impfen lassen
von der sache her wer zuerst geimpft
werden darf ist es vielleicht ist es
vielleicht sinnvoll die risikogruppen
was sie unter krise gucken bezeichnen
weil ich kenne persönlich menschen die
wirklich sehr sehr erkrankt sind an
diesem corona büros also und ich muss
dazu sagen ich bin die erste die mich
impfen lässt
und ich arbeite in einem beruf wo ich
als gefährdet gelten
und ich mache es gutes an ist an den
impfstoff dass man hoffentlich wieder
back to normal kann das war nämlich zeit
ich selber hab gar keine angst mich
vorkommen dass sie infizieren habe ich
hatte schiss hervor wie die mir diesen
impfstoff geben zu lassen wir sind bild
und wir liefern dir deine news auf
youtube zum nächsten video kommst du
hier
und vergiss bitte nicht unseren kanal zu
abonnieren